hey nice house you got here real ritzy
way better than my bench oh wow you
really made yourself at home huh oh
there you are who's this weirdo and why
is he setting up a
huge alien computer in our living room
okay
first of all that alien computer is a
very expensive and surprisingly
operational bounty 5000 so uh you're
welcome what 5 000
i've got just the thing a small time
local gangster by the name of nine talk
she took my favorite knife she's got an
operation out in the slums
maybe a killer and get my knife back
then we'll talk maybe take you out to
glumpi's to celebrate all right so we we
just head out to the slums no [ __ ] you
gotta use the bounty 5000 to initiate a
bounty that's what i went through all
the trouble of setting it up for
my knife we're looking for the gateway
to the slums i guess look it shouldn't
be too far listen just follow the
waypoint that's why you're wearing that
fancy suit isn't it i mean it's got the
augmented reality thing on it right
[Music]
have once again backfired this time
making them far far hornier than
ever however things don't have to be
this way as chancellor under my
five-year plan all drugs will be
eradicated
ever been top side oh lord
oh
it's a top cider not interested
hey oh my god i broke my leg coming down
that pipe be careful sorry to hear that
well well
look what we got here fresh meat hey
there fresh meat welcome to the slums
fresh meat
oh boy here we go
kid what's wrong fresh meat you scared
of a little kid you have a little kid
look at me look at me
what are you doing come on he's just a
kid don't shoot him oh you don't want to
shoot me just cause your gun said not to
just because you're your little gun oh
but yeah okay look how shootable i look
i am not shooting a kid go ahead do it
shoot me fresh me shoot me see what
happens oh don't i look so shootable ah
you shot me i'm dead eh all right there
are you happy now well i i didn't think
we'd be allowed to kill him normally
killing children in games isn't isn't
allowed but he's dead we killed this kid
are you happy now we killed a kid a kid
is dead now there goes our e for
everybody rating
hey you can't pass through here it's
nine towards term jesus enough with
everyone getting in our way we just want
to kill nine torg yeah right you killed
nine torque get lost heal
you just killed chase and here we go
we're gonna have to kill some of these
poor foot soldiers to prove ourselves
around here these people think we're
weak not on my watch what are you some
kind of bounty hunter the thrones are
full yeah this is nine horns
they're shooting in a shoot back come on
shoot back it's gonna be so easy to kill
you nine turds trained us real good
we're the toughest enemies in the game i
think
wow all right you we got them all
usually these tours aren't so hostile
something must be going on
let's look around for somebody who can
help us
oh hey you want to see a cool party
trick i used to do amy at those spinny
platforms come on come on give it a shot
it'll be fun
yeah i told you did you see how fun that
was i call it my glob shot it comes out
of my trick hole all gatlings have a
different kind of trick hole mine does
this boy you are learning a lot today
aren't you
yes yes huh oh my god i can do this all
day doesn't this rule god i love spewing
big gloopy globs
hey
did you just kill everyone hold up don't
shoot i i got an idea it's another trick
up my little slimy sleeve try hitting
him with my glob shot take your time and
aim right you're gonna kill us now
oh whoa perfect shot you nailed it how
sick was that
oh [ __ ] you i'm sick of this i wanna
tear through someone's guts oh i think
they're talking about gene tonight [ __ ]
you got it freak we've had enough of
your [ __ ] yeah it's your fault
stevulax is dead i was in love with him
did you know that i loved him and now
his head's coming just the way it should
be [ __ ] hey guess what i have another
secret trick you can use the power of
negotiation let's try reasoning with
these guys knock on the door tell me how
you
you insufferable
when i'm loose oh
who's there who are you uh hey hello
there friends oh i i think it's the
buyer hey are you the buyer
no i'm just here to do my laundry it's
it's even clean i just i'm a laundry
head can't stop washing stuff over here
this room's off limits everything you
need is in the front get out of here
good luck with your laundry i really
thought that was gonna be the buyer we
don't know what they sound like so we
have no way of knowing if it was them or
not okay i'll just say it that plan was
dumb i'm willing to accept some of the
blame but don't do any more dumb stuff
can we try it again and do it right this
time
okay this must be the buyer hey buddy
are you the buyer
no it's me your lover stevulax i'm back
from the dead what oh my god baby you're
alive your voice sounds different no
let's play along no shooting
wait you're not my dad lover stebulax
you're just a person oh what a good
trick you tricked me nice job they told
us this barrier was a real prankster oh
you come on that was pretty [ __ ] up
that joke is gonna [ __ ] me
up you got him good okay though but
enough of that uh let's show them the
product
all right here's the product a genuine
talking knife i gotta be honest with you
he's a real piece of [ __ ] he's extremely
violent he basically only talks about
wanting to kill people in very
disturbing ways q i'm gonna carve out
your cavity gonna make it three times as
big your it's just gonna drop right out
of there i see what i'm talking about oh
perfect that's exactly what we're
looking for yeah yeah great go ahead
feel free to inspect it try him out see
how he feels in your hand yeah yeah free
me let's go let's go psycho on these
[ __ ] actually you want to just swing
out the air a bit like far away from us
yeah thanks
come on what are you
oh [ __ ] yes thank you pleased to meet
you i'm knifey now use me use me let me
stop these [ __ ] hands oh just a
reminder uh don't do anything crazy when
you're holding the knife just like look
at it see if you like it put it back
yeah thank you
oh [ __ ] yeah
yes more more i need more stabbing
definitely nine torque but let's put a
pin in the whole gene thing how do we
get out of here with my tether ability
i'm more than just a knife you're racist
i can tether too look up and latch on
here there we go [ __ ] cool right you
gotta use me to swing across this sludge
oh [ __ ] yeah not as good as stabbing but
still pretty good well all right where
to next the sludge works processing
plant nine talk was talking about some
trader she had to deal with probably
another one of her clones five tall or
six toggle whatever i don't know there's
too many now there's too many talks how
many clones are there who the [ __ ] cares
stop thinking so hard and just look for
the big sludge work sign i want to stab
somebody
oh a lug locks use me i can open those
up real good and there's loot inside for
you too win-win yes there we go got him
open for you what happened to june he
used to be a hero yeah he used to be
hard to tell these days right towards
the end the only thing i was cutting for
him was sandwiches not even the good
ones peanut butter sandwiches and no
[ __ ] jelly
[Music]
[Music]
that was
[Applause]
hey i'm still here you can still use me
if you want
i can deflect attacks did you know that
i'm not just all about stabbing well i'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but i can also deflect attacks
you know this sludge matches your toxic
personality
[Music]
[Music]
incoming lasers
laser just for you
i'm taking you with me
stay alive i think she's basically done
for